well first off once again thank you for
attending so that you know this room is
not empty and I'm not just talking to
myself that's nice but I don't have like
more to talk about or another
presentation or anything like that so we
can just go ahead and jump into
questions I do have the presentation
here if you want to move to a particular
slide we were pretty rushed for time so
I didn't get to go into much detail on
anything but I'm just opening it up
completely anything you want to ask
about technical non-technical just
anything yes so I'm gonna repeat the
question just so everyone can hear it
but he was saying as a maintainer of an
open source project what are things that
maintainer x' can do in order to create
more diversity on their projects well
I'm obviously going to first off talk
about enum focus in order to be a an
affiliated product project or a
sponsored project as a part of non focus
you do have to have a code of conduct
that is in line with the num focus code
of conduct that's one particular thing
so that people know that there is
governance around problems that may pop
up right and believe me they actually do
pop up okay so and then also being a
part of another organization that has
had some experience dealing with issues
that have popped up on projects gives
people more confidence right but one
thing that I think that a lot of people
overlook is that in open source projects
that having some sort of guide to your
first contribution to a project is I
feel like the most important thing that
you can possibly do right so creating
that welcome space for people to be able
to contribute and know that their
contributions are going that they're
doing the right thing in order to
contribute to the project right what
does it look like to create your first
you know pull request what is it like
what is the procedure right how do
people like what is the culture of the
project right so that they can feel more
confident in making that first leap
right because
once I mean like I said I don't really
contribute a lot of code or anything
anymore but I used to quite a bit
actually and once you get past that
first commit usually you feel much more
confident that you can do it again right
and so and then also one thing I also
mentioned to people is that you know if
you do notice something happening if you
notice somebody being bullied or ignored
or you know something but you're not
comfortable with right be a good ally
and say something okay and it doesn't
take much time to say you know what
let's let this person finish their
thought right it really really doesn't
and it sets the tone for the culture
right that we are making space for each
other we are making space for people to
finish what they're saying that we do
value people's opinions right
does that help it sounds like you have
more here what are you talking like give
it to me absolutely I think that's a
really great question right because I
mean as somebody who reviews a lot of
open source projects right you see the
like 500 little commits from like the
one time committers and then you have
like five or six active people on a
project that are actually the ones that
are pushing everything forward right and
people are wondering like why is this
long tail of committers why why are they
not staying right or why are they not
getting more involved or what happened
there right and that's I feel like it
has to do with that you know feeling
welcome right feeling like they so even
having somebody reach out and say you
know like hey like we noticed that you
had your first commit here or something
like that you know what did you think of
it get feedback like what was what was
the experience like you know kind of
fostering those kinds of things and then
also I don't want to you know I feel
like Sprint's are big
a really really great opportunity for
people to help each other feel more
welcome in open source communities and I
have noticed that a lot of sprinters
after the Sprint is over they're just
like well that was fun
I'll see y'all later peace right and
like and it's just and it's just not
really that's that's really not what we
want right we want people who are going
to be a part of the community that we
have more ideas but let's also be very
real right like if you don't understand
what the road map looks like if you
don't understand how the work that
you're doing fits into the overall
project itself if you don't really
understand like if it's just a big pain
basically to work with this team but
very very unlikely to come back right
and then not to discount the people who
make the one commit because it's just a
bug fix like those are probably not the
ones you're going to get to stay anyway
they're just probably a user and they're
they're just like they want to have the
bug fix right yeah it's a hard problem
though I agree like creating welcoming
open communities is very difficult yeah
yeah I've seen a lot of initiatives
strain to recruit women into
male-dominated industries let's focus on
how to retain or maybe create cultures
that want to stay right do you have or
could you comment a little bit on what
you see is some of the main barriers
that exist and
best practices sure this actually gets a
little tricky to tell you the truth
right because one of the statistics I
actually did not include in the in the
slide just because I could bombard
people with statistics all day long and
I was you know this last week I actually
went and refreshed my statistics often
you know like the Bureau of Labor and
Statistics and things like that but
generally like you said women are not
staying in computer science so it's not
even just imagine a matter of people
entering the field they're not staying
right so people my age in particular
generally aren't there anymore they've
moved on to something else I found a
non-technical role maybe adjacent to a
technical role or something like that
and not necessarily in the area right
you know that they started in and some
of that is natural career progression
but I also feel like there is it goes
back to the lack of women and leadership
right if there is no path forward and
you don't see other people being
promoted what is the point right more
likely to try something else right and
then also something I've seen on my own
teams as women feel like they have to
constantly reapply for their job okay
when they're constantly having to rattle
off their credentials over and over and
over and over again every time a new
person joins the team right and so
there's a trust issue there that I can't
really put my finger on and so first off
I think that you know building trust in
teams it does take time right and
burning in a team is really really a
painful process and then once you have a
really nice trust organization things
people are gonna leave people are only
staying in jobs you know an average of
two and a half years now so it's not
uncommon to see turn in your teams as
well but trying to maintain that
consistency and path forward and make
sure that you know it will
that they will be just as understood
moving forward as well because one of
the other stories I hear from women
anecdotally and I don't have any data
behind this I am a data person so a lot
of this is anecdotal but hearing people
say that oh yeah my manager was
fantastic I joined this organization
because this manager just you know
really lit a fuse and I felt really
really connected and I felt like I had a
path forward and they've really really
cared and then they left and now I'm
under this other person he doesn't give
a crap what I have to say about anything
and they feel like they're off on the
side and so you know I think that there
are organizational issues that need to
be worked out I think there are pay
issues that need to be worked out I
think their leadership issues that need
to be worked out and then amongst
ourselves just taking the opportunity to
you know remind our our co-workers that
we do value them right and that we want
to be a part of them and it even can be
things that are very simple one thing
that I've noticed also on teams is that
if there are a lot of guys like they'll
even just planning social events that
maybe not the whole team is invited to
write can also be a problem right and
I'm not saying don't do that at all but
they do have to create some inclusion
right because then the more people feel
accepted and listened to and like their
ideas matter and pass forward they're
more likely they are to stay right and
so but yeah it is it's shocking the
number of women in computer science that
after all of those different you know
30% of women you know having a major
computer science getting their first job
after passing the bar of being the 60
you know the 40% that don't go into
technical fields and then 10 years later
dropping out right moving into sometimes
completely different fields right it's
it's very real yeah
earlier in your presentation you
mentioned something I thought was really
interesting
whenever companies use open source
software they have to be really
cognizant of yeah there we go
people injecting proprietary software
like through pool requests and then your
company using it and then it opens you
up to a lot to liability issues and
stuff I was curious if you could expand
on the process for determining whether
or not that's happening or if there's a
risk of it I don't have once again I
have no data behind this right but I
don't think it happens very often I
really don't mean especially on an
active project right the whole point is
to have governance in place that you
know if somebody especially if somebody
sees something like a copyright IBM or
Google or something like that you know
that someone would not approve that
request right that pull request right
and so making sure that you do have the
right you know governance and and
leadership in order to be able to review
things and have awareness of whether or
not that's happening the reason it comes
up is that you know I have to do a lot
of interfacing with leadership
organizations right and they're always
asking about you know like what is the
risk that we're taking on why you know
why would we trust this like how do we
know the governance is working how do we
know that this is not happening and you
know what what is our exposure here
right is it a critical system or is
something over on the side or is it
something that's going to be customer
facing is it something that's going to
be internal you know all those things
like that so that if it were to happen
that we have a plan in place of what we
would do right I think that sometimes
organizations spend a lot of time you
know absolutely let's prevent the
problem from happening right but we live
in a world where we are imperfect right
and sometimes the mettle of an
organization can really be tested by how
we respond to problems that come up all
right
and so having you know things at place
to understand what would happen what
would we do if we did find the stat and
find out that this was happening right
usually the answer is that you know
we're gonna pull it all right but the
biggest reason that open-source projects
that I want to use on my team don't get
approved as security issues not
necessarily because of you know any kind
of governance or you know lack of site
for like proprietary software anything
like that it's usually security that's
right I mean as far as I know I've never
seen an oil gas company open source
anything ever right so there's that
right but one of the things that I when
I have had to talk to organizations like
that I make it really clear that the
risk of sharing software and tools is
actually very low especially in data
science the real values of the data
right but that's really what's going to
be the differentiator on projects and
the ability to you know take this and
make more money on it or something like
that so I you know I have had those
conversations but yeah it's I actually
could name a couple different industries
that I feel that people feel like
they're they're somehow special but they
are using open-source which is great
right so I mean that's something at
least right but I worked at worked with
oil and gas industry
a couple of different times in my career
usually more in like a consulting kind
of capacity so I'm able to at least
bring these issues up but nobody's ever
decided to nobody I've ever talked to
has decided to open-source anything
that's very very cool I'm gonna have to
check out the Norway oil and gas
industry
[Laughter]
but what kind of mistakes have you seen
like yourself or other people make it's
like one time with bicycles are doing
and accept that I have in my mind this
at times someone says like hey we're
going to do this project in our present
leave metric is going to be this and
then you're like wow there's like a
little busted
look at that metric and then they show
an error bar and they're embarrassing
mints and they're like well the effect
you want is like prank a goal right it's
much love lately her power is like can
we not do that can we do something else
Briony unable right I've been unable to
convince people right absolutely and so
communication is such an important part
of a successful project right I mean we
just can't really get around it and you
know and to be you know to caveat this I
struggle with this as well right I mean
everyone does and so one of the things
that I have noticed though I've been
very fortunate to be able to work with
some executive coaching and like some
you know leadership training and things
like that and one of the things that
they have really really like beat into
my head at this point is that sometimes
when somebody's feeling very very
resistant to an idea but they're feeling
unheard right so once again let them
talk let them tell you all the things
that are wrong and let them like feel
like you're really listening and
understanding where they're coming from
right and it's an incredibly effective
way to begin conversations right so that
you're able to diffuse the argument
right and so that's the first thing and
so let people say their piece let them
talk
this let them let them go right and
occasionally actually somebody has a
good point okay so I'm gonna be clear
that is the exception not the rule
so
so you know let you know let that happen
right then the other thing is who is the
person who is your audience right am I
talking to c-level executives am i
talking to an engineering team am i
talking to another group of data
scientists am I talking to product
managers who am I talking to and I will
try to speak their language as much as I
possibly can right so if I'm talking to
a bunch of product managers maybe I
start going in on the a/b testing really
hard and really explain you know why
this is not a good effect or why this is
an underpowered test or why we don't
want to do this right or if I'm talking
to an engineering team I may talk about
architecture or why this is not
happening or what the technical problems
or issues might be right or if I'm
talking to c-level executives try to
build pretty pictures because that seems
to be very very effective so but who is
the audience what am i what am I looking
at and sometimes let's just be real
sometimes it's gonna take a while right
my favorite thing that seems to happen
I've noticed over time is sometimes it
takes a while to plant a seed with
somebody and when you know you've really
finally gotten them to understand where
you're coming from you just repeat over
and over and over and over again as many
different ways as you can express it and
then one day they come back to you and
say you know what I got this great idea
or you know what I noticed I noticed
that our error bars are way too big of
this and that's when you know you
finally like have Inception to them into
understanding right and so people love
it when it they feel it like when it's
their idea right and so that's fine
because one of the things I tell people
especially managers that report to me
and things like that like do you want to
be right or do you want to move the
project forward right let's not have
that fight whether or not we're right
let's have the effect that we're trying
to make on the project that we're
working on right it doesn't matter who
feels like they came up with the idea
the point is all of us are on the
look for delivering it right so but yeah
repeat repeat repeat again we're hanging
over and over and over again and also
sometimes you do have to wait for the
strategic failure I'm just going to say
that that like make sure it's well
documented make sure that all of
everything make sure you do your cya all
right but sometimes you're not going to
be able to help a project not fail right
and you just have to be able to let it
go right and ultimately see what happens
right and there are a lot of different
ways for us to arrive at at a conclusion
for a project and like let's just see
what happens right like but I you know
sometimes you just talked and talked and
talked to you're blue in the face and at
some point you just have to say okay
I've said my piece I've given you my
opinion I have a lot of experience in
this area this is what I'm telling you I
get it like you're not you're going in a
different direction and you could let it
go yeah
this is a bit of a two-part question so
the first part is when you're honest
smaller data science team a lot of times
like predicting the consulting you feel
like you're wearing a lot of different
hats when it comes like data engineering
cloud deployment data analysis that kind
of thing it's like how do you balance
where you spend your time learning but
then the second part is how do you spell
like balance the time spent researching
things versus actually like getting down
on coding things that actually solve
problems yeah absolutely
so as I mentioned I am in a leadership
position I have been for a while now but
I am definitely a player-coach
if ever there was one okay people who
have been on my teams before know this
for a fact I roll up my sleeves and I
get down and dirty right and so I it's
and so I think it's a very interesting
question because how I I realized pretty
early on that if my team is blocked by
the issue that I said I was going to put
the fix in for then I'm actually not
helping my team right so sometimes I
jump around a lot right was like am i
working on getting more resources am i
working on building a better
relationship with our data engineering
team am i working on you know making
sure that the sea level is giving us
coverage that we need you know all of
those things like that I can jump around
quite a bit right and the only way that
I can describe it and I don't know if
this is helpful and I have no guidance
really whether or not this is working
but at the same times like what is what
is the most important thing I need to be
doing today right and focus on that
right and sometimes it really has to be
on a daily basis that I have to reject
all right so like does my team need more
help do we need to you know do research
something Freight or do I need to be
focusing and like sometimes I can be way
more effective with a PowerPoint than I
can be with a piece of code right so
just being flexible I think is really
really important
but I do also believe very strongly in
the preterite player/coach mentality
because I hope that my teams know that I
have their back and that I can jump in
and help out and code all night with
them just alongside them and that we get
there together as a team right so and I
feel like it works and it creates a lot
of camaraderie on the teams yeah I hope
I don't know you guys actually can
answer that better than I can
[Laughter]
suppose I upstairs will be this by X
percent yep and you know it's like this
could code anyway because it's super
noisy now it's your responsibility to
motivate the whole team to work towards
that somehow well the way I describe
this because I get this question from
other managers as well right is that
there are company goals their division
goals there are team goals and then
there are Katrina's goals okay and so
sometimes when something is going on
that maybe it's really great when all
those things are in complete alignment
right but they rarely are alright and so
when that happens you know sometimes you
just level with people and let them know
hey we just have to do this because it's
table stakes and we're being asked to do
it right
we got to take one for the team and
we're gonna have to do this
other times take that if you do have a
better solution push for that in tandem
right say okay here's what you guys have
asked for but maybe take a look at the
work that we're doing right here and how
it might be a better direction for us to
go in right and it does create a lot of
work at the same time as part of that
communication and being very
transparent about you know what's going
on because the thing I know for sure
doesn't work is saying we shouldn't do
that I think that's a terrible idea that
will never fly absolutely not
so but yeah it's it's hard and hopefully
[Music]
organizations you know I'm very rarely
in the position or at least I've been
fortunate and very rarely be in the
position where I'm responsible for
something that I cannot it all buy into
right but that would I'm not sure how I
would feel about that right it has to be
an organism it has to be a conversation
right and I want to be in an
organization that values experience and
and maybe other ways of doing things
right but we all have to keep in mind
that there's possibility that we're
wrong okay and that that is exactly the
way to go right so you always keep that
in mind that like you know can I kind of
look at this a different way or can I
relate to this in a different way in
order to get us closer to where we want
to be right
there are a lot of projects in open
source environment like for any tasks
there are usually two projects and we
can use some of them we can try another
one I'd like you to share your
experiences and managers so how you find
balance between like when half of your
team wanna try like every project to
apply to your like every open source
project applying to your work and other
couple that team wants to stay with all
Fortran library so easily a balance did
you find them so what's your experience
with that in my if we have time I love
to let teams bake it off like just let
them both try it and see what happens
right and generally let the team Duke it
out alright it's actually one of my
favorite things to do believe it or not
but rarely do we have that time by the
way but when we do have the time yeah
absolutely you feel strongly about this
solution you feel strongly about this
solution go for it let's see what
happens right we don't always have that
luxury right and so a lot of times
especially we're in their tight
deadlines we have to make a call
right and so being willing to make that
hard call is part of what we have to do
right that being able to lead a team and
make the call that like we're gonna go
in this direction and you know I you
know keep an open mind about it right so
that people stay engaged in the in the
in the in the project right because I
you know especially having been a
developer in the past I didn't agree
with every technical decision right but
we could agree upon the fact that we did
get to some happy place in the end you
know there like I said before that there
is a there are a lot of different paths
to how to get to the end of a project
right or get to the end of a deliverable
and so let's make room for the fact that
like maybe this time we go this
direction maybe the next time we go this
direction or something like that right
without creating a lot of chaos right
and that's the big thing is that you
know diffusing that sort of like I I
don't like this decision so I'm gonna
take all my toys and go home you know
kind of mentality is the thing that I
really try hard to defuse as much as
possible all right but yeah sometimes
you got to make a hard call and you do
the best you can and hopefully you know
I tell my teams this all the time that
if I'm batting about 75 80 percent I
feeling pretty good about myself all
right
and leave open the fact that you know
I'm a human and I make mistakes too and
you know but that we're going to be in
it together yeah I do it's a lot small
things
to a model we know a big effect a green
wondering kind of the things that you
listed there like which of those do you
find yourself most often like concerned
about like something and creating sort
of like
what okay so if the the question is like
what is the technology that's going to
enslave humanity I don't know okay I'm
not going to take a stance on that one
but the thing that keeps me up the most
at night is actually the introduction of
bias into machine learning that is the
one that absolutely makes me crazy and
why I mentioned it first actually
because you know there's something to be
said for optimizing and creating models
in order to like make a quick buck or a
short-term
you know effect but sometimes we forget
about the long-term effects of what we
are finding right and so and what what
effect that is having on the society or
the culture that we choose to live in
right so yes some things may be
profitable in the short term but is it
creating the sustainable long term
growth and market place that we want it
to be in right or is it creating the the
thing that we want to see in the world
and then also where does a novelty play
into this whole thing right I would hate
a world where I never saw anything novel
and that all of my most base you know
impulses were catered to by every
machine learning model around me to make
me like a more a more a better consumer
but not necessarily a better person
right and how do I break out of those
bubbles break out of those patterns
right and it feels like already we're in
a situation where people have to seek
out new information or seek out novel
experiences or seek out novel
recommendations right as opposed to just
constantly constantly being you know in
this you know self reinforcing bubble
and so that's the one that really really
keeps me up at night the other one that
I actually I think about quite a bit
when I'm working on like more how I put
like more nefarious or security oriented
type things
is that when you're dealing with these
adversarial systems right this is
actually something I mean stealing
directly from Greg here in the first in
the first row but that this they become
so good that the signal disappears right
and we can no longer tell the difference
right that as things are adversarially
getting better and better and better and
better and better that we can no longer
actually see that signal anymore that
we've actually learned you know the
adversaries have learned how to be the
machines right and that because we have
to be able to show a statistically
significant amount of signal in order
for the model to work right that's
something that also really really
bothers me because I see it quite often
especially on the security side more so
than anywhere else that you know you're
looking at somebody who's breaking into
a system or something like that and you
can almost see them adapt almost
immediately right or they're creating
that novel input that we can't account
for it just yet right
[Music]
so to set the stage a little bit I'm
still at the beginning of my career so
on one hand I'm trying to keep an open
mind towards different ways that my
career could get up but at the same time
I want to have a solid answer for what
do you see yourself doing in five years
and I've also noticed that there's a lot
of granularity when it comes to the
different sections of data science like
you can kind of fragmented into analyst
data engineering etc etc and even within
those sections there's still
fragmentation I was wondering do you
notice any towards the the goal of maybe
like finding your niche do you notice
any trends as far as when people are
exploring what personality types maybe
tend to correlate with what kind of
positions or what do certain people tend
to find you know I mean
or maybe advice yeah I was gonna say I
don't really know if I you know I every
time I think try to guess what I think
one of somebody on my team wants I'm
always wrong so I just ask all right
where do you want to go right and what
do you want to do with your career I
believe that if you don't create some
sort of path to self-actualization you
lose your employees pretty fast right
and so it's very very important to pay
attention to what people want
first off right and then on the other
side of it as you probably have noticed
I've actually been all over the place
right I worked on platforms I worked on
data science stuff I worked on business
stuff I've worked on low level stuff
I've worked on government stuff I've
worked on all these different things and
I wouldn't have it any other way to tell
you the truth because it's been fun as
hell okay so like for somebody like me
and I can really only speak to my
experiences is that you know I love
learning new things I love being able to
move into these other areas I love being
able to take techniques and and applying
them to something new and to try
something new and that's just something
that works for me and it may not work
for other people right but that's my
thing
so I don't know it's it's I feel like
careers are just so incredibly personal
you know that you gotta be careful on
that one and but I do recommend that you
you know at least try a couple different
things before you decide on a path and
also be flexible knowing that where you
think you might be going might not be
where you actually end up okay
yeah something all right well thank you
so much for attending
[Applause]